mario cherche c'est donc essentiellement
de l'hydrologie au mieux de perdre une
seule qui ait fortement différentes de
l'hydrologie qu'on peut observer dans le
sud du pays ma recherche se déroule au
lac qui est le lac le plus au nord au
canada
j'ai pu observer que les écoulements
préférentiel cause de l'érosion sous la
surface du sol ce qui est assez
différente de ce qu'on observe dans le
sud où habituellement l'érosion se
produit surtout en surface ces
écoulements le très concentré ce qu'ils
engendrent c'est l'érosion seul à
certains endroits très précis
le dégel du pergélisol engendre la pose
de la salinité de l'eau ce qui va causer
puisqu'il ya le potentiel de causer
dexter changement dans l'écosystème du
lac mordante
lorsque c'est tout là entre dans l'est
ce que je tente donc de déterminer dans
ma recherche sait où sont situés ces
chemins d'écoulement préférentiel de
quoi ils ont là là c'est quoi leur rôle
pour le transfert des sédiments et de
matières en solutions vers le lac
ouareau